so those of you who don't know I'm a bit
of a metal gear Paris Metal Gear Rising
takes place after Metal Gear Solid 4 at
first it was going to take place before
it now apparently it takes place after
Metal Gear Solid 4 you play as right now
ridin was the biggest bait-and-switch in
videogame history and Metal Gear Solid 2
Metal Gear Solid 4 they're made of a
complete badass as they you get to play
as him as a complete badass cyborg ninja
now the gameplay in the game is actually
it's a lot of fun I didn't think I'd
like it I actually didn't want to like
it why because I don't like the fact
that after Metal Gear Solid 4 ride and
finds absolution he finds resolved and
now he has to gear up and go back out
there I feel like it trivializes things
in Metal Gear Rising it's a hack and
slash game it's a completely different
vibe Metal Gear Solid the Metal Gear
Solid series it was tactical espionage
action you know stealth stealth kills
this you take a sword you go out there
and you just slice things to [ __ ] and
you have a normal attack you have your
strong attack and then that it it does
feel like just a generic hack and slash
you have your one attack to attack hack
and slash now one thing it does have it
has this really cool mode where you hold
r1 everything slows down and that's we
just pinpoint you just slice everything
up and just everything falls apart
sequentially just in sections it's
really pinpoint I found that the game
did lag at that point when you're just
slicing everything up maybe there's just
too much crap on the screen I hope they
fix that hope that was just a demo
glitch but I'm just saying it happened
to me I had a lot of fun with the game
is that move enough to carry the entire
game I don't know I feel like if that
move was not even in the game it would
just be a one attack to attack hack and
slash game I wanted to see where right
and goes and his adventure but I'm
hoping it's more than just a hack and
slash I'm hoping it fits in the Metal
Gear Solid but that's the metal your
cell appearance in me what's it fun yeah
fun enough to buy more than a demo I
don't know the demo was fun any more
than that you might get repetitive